الجيش الروسي في الهجوم في
التدريبات الرئيسية بالذخيرة الحية مع قوات بيلا الروسية
داخل بيلاروسيا ولكن بالقرب من
الحدود مع أوكرانيا يتدرب على
هجوم هائل ،
شرح القائد هدفه
اليوم في مظاهرة بالذخيرة الحية ،
وتم عرض معركة دفاعية ثم
ضربة مضادة  لاستعادة موقع القوات
على طول الخط الأمامي ، يقول إن
هذه القوات هي جزء من أكثر من
000 جندي حشدتهم روسيا حول
أوكرانيا ، وتعتقد الولايات المتحدة أن واشنطن
تخشى أن تكون بيلاروسيا إحدى
منصات إطلاق هجوم على أوكرانيا
رغم أن موسكو تدعي أنها فعلت ذلك.  لا توجد مثل هذه
الخطط
في هذه الأوقات العصيبة للغاية ، فإن روسيا
تستعرض قوتها العسكرية حقًا ، ليس
فقط من خلال هذه التدريبات الضخمة هنا في
بيلاروسيا مع التدريبات في أماكن أخرى ، بالإضافة إلى
إشراك بعض أكثر الوحدات القتالية النخبة في روسيا ، حيث
أشرف على التدريبات النووية
بالقرب من حدود الناتو والتي شملت بعضًا من
معظم روسيا  أسلحة خطيرة مثل
صاروخ جو - أرض الذي تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت
kinjal أو صاروخ التداخل  صواريخ باليستية ميدانية تم
إطلاقها من قاذفة موبا ،
أطلقت روسيا صواريخ من الجو والبر
والبحر لتظهر ترسانة الكرملين النووية
، والهدف الرئيسي من التدريبات الجارية
هو العمل على اتخاذ إجراءات لإلحاق
هزيمة مضمونة بالعدو ،
وقال الجنرال بوتين إن
القوة العسكرية واسعة النطاق  تأتي اللعب
لأن الولايات المتحدة تعتقد أن فلاديمير بوتين قد
اتخذ بالفعل قرارًا بغزو
أوكرانيا ، وأعتقد أنه يجب علينا
الاستمرار في المحاولة حتى
اللحظة الأخيرة حتى لم يعد ذلك
ممكنًا ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه
إذا نظرت إلى الموقف الذي هو عليه
من الواضح اليوم أنه اتخذ
قرارًا وأنهم ينتقلون
إلى المواقع الصحيحة ليكونوا قادرين على
شن
هجوم.
وتنفي روسيا أنها ستهاجم أوكرانيا لكن
قيادتها حتى الآن لم تعلن عن
أي جدول زمني لانسحاب
القوات الهائلة التي وضعتها حول
أوكرانيا
فريد بلاتكين cnn obuz lewanovski belarus